okay so today's stuff we may not have
that I may not lecture that the entire
time depending on how my hands
voice holds up today we're jumping ahead
let's say Epictetus to the ants we're
jumping ahead about a millennium so
we're skipping over a lot of stuff in
the history of philosophy and you know
there are some people that would have
been really good for us to study had we
more time and you know the capacity to
focus in on all these different things
but we have to make some selections and
so we didn't read somebody like seeing
st. Augustine another great religious
thinker we are going to read an some and
we're going to read the 3rd day Thomas
Aquinas starting I think next week after
we finish the answer but I want to tell
you a little bit about Anselm so if
you're making this big jump we're kind
of shifting gears I want to tell you a
little bit about Ann Sullivan and then
what we're doing with this this class so
this guy Ansem he was a monk what I'm
office do they wear different clothes
right
they're like nuns not as the female
equivalent of mom what sets them apart
from other people other than wearing
strange clothes they can't get married
that that's an important point why not
yeah often you're right well oftentimes
they they frame it in terms well I can't
get married but that's ok because I'm
married to God and are married in Jesus
or you know but you know it's not the
monasticism is not just fun Christianity
you also have Islamic mistakes the Sufis
you have Hindu and Buddhist monks what
are they what are they doing what's
their life about anyone know this is an
area where there's well actually a lot
of monasteries and seminaries nunneries
one of those people I'm guessing since
none of you know that none of you were
attracted to that sort of life monk yet
it comes from Greek and it comes from
the word Monaco's which means alone
originally these were people who went
off in the desert by themselves and why
do you think somebody would go off in
the desert by themselves because they
like the scene in a theater they can't
stand their fellow coworkers
that could be a reason right people get
away why else in the beginning of the
Christian here why do these people go
off in the desert all the ideas just
take guesses
avoid the roman soldiers that could be a
reason
it wasn't the reason yeah okay to see if
they could do is that see if they could
handle it sort of like a boot camp and
some of the things that they did were
pretty hardcore top stuff a lot of
fasting vigils you know trying to purify
themselves what i yeah yeah that's what
that's what monasticism was about it was
withdrawing from other things so that
they could devote themselves to to
prayer prayer is a communication that's
not such as going off and mumbling to
yourself it's it's supposed to be some
sort of communication with something
divine right and so in all the different
world religions when people go off and
become monastics whether they're male or
female amongst turn-ons they're doing
often they're they're withdrawing from
ordinary secular life to try to live a
more religious life a more sacred life
and Ansel's was one of those guys he
wanted to do that when he was pretty
young the reason why we've got to
trigger names for him Anselm of
Canterbury or back borrow stuff most
does where he came from
it's now in Italy it was part of the
kingdom at that time called burgundy so
we get burgundy wine from from that
right and that part of Burgundy is part
of Italy now so if you're Italian you
call him handsome to host because you
want to claim as your guy if you're
French then you focus on wick the
monastery that you go to that which is
called back which is in Normandy so you
call on some
back and if you're English or an English
speaker like us then you call him the
Anselm of Canterbury because that's
where he wound up and actually lived out
a good portion of this his life so a
handsome wanted to become a monk and he
was a pretty successful monk you know
what would success be as a monk he would
be presumably you know making a lot of
money becoming the abbot that you know
wealth power we talked about these
before having lots of friends and
influencing people no understanding God
that's what that's what he was
interested that's what monks were
supposed to be interested in it doesn't
actually work that way for all monks and
nuns never dead there are always some
people in it for the wrong reasons and
actually if you look at Anselm's letters
you find as he actually became an abbot
Bishop he had to discipline people who
were in it for the wrong reasons and he
just say I you're not supposed to be
doing this you're not supposed to be
getting drunk you're not supposed to be
out of the town with the women you know
all sorts of things along those lines
but Ansel himself was very much
interested in learning as much as he
could at that time if you wanted to go
to school one of the places to do it was
a monastery because that was one of the
few places where people were on the
whole educated monasteries were were the
places where Western literature was
saved and one of the things that these
monks would do was they would copy books
by hand so a lot of the books that we
have came to us because of monks not
because they felt like doing it here
they wanted to it was a religious duty
copying these things out by hand and if
you do that sort of thing you guys know
this from taking somebody else's notes
I'm copying them you learn a lot in the
process don't you so it's a way to
become acquainted kid so Ansel boasted
back he's not getting a bunk and he
started studying with this guy LAN frog
who used to be a lawyer
and then society you didn't want to be a
lawyer anymore and he became a monk and
then he and some kind of thought about
things and then he decided he had what
we call the delicious vocation he wanted
to become a monk and like you said it
set himself apart so he didn't engage in
prayer and get closer he's got by this
time they're no longer at the desert
this is you know just you know the
countryside and the ants home you know
stays at his monastery he he eventually
becomes the prior sort of like the
second of command and then when the
abbot dies they elected me heaven he did
not like that
he was the kind of guy he's sort of a
typical academic he wanted to study the
things that he wanted to study and he
didn't want to exercise responsibility
you know if you you guys will learn this
as you get older some of you have
probably already been in roles where you
had some responsibility right yeah
student council right you had some
responsibility well maybe you didn't
then but as you get older you find out
the more things you get responsible for
the less you can actually do that you
want to do what Anselm wanted to do is
to think about philosophy and theology
and about God and they kept on because
he was a smart guy because he was honest
they kept on giving it more and more and
more responsibility
eventually he goes to England and well
he's in England the King actually makes
him Archbishop and he was so against
being Archbishop they had to dandy
actually forced the the what was the
thing they call the the staff of the
bishop has I forget the name of it but
you all know the answer the circular
thing
then forcing it what's up no that's not
a sickle Crozier was it called Bert
maybe they had to force it into his hand
they had to drag him to the Cathedral
they gave him a bloody nose in the
process that's how much this can I
didn't want to be in charge of place and
yet he he stayed in charge of the rest
of his life and then that the King
actually changed his mind when he found
that the insulin wasn't going to do what
he wanted him to do and there was a lot
of church-state stuff now one of the
things that the Anselm is particularly
known for in the history of philosophy
is a certain kind of argument an
ontological that's what we call this
kind of argument since the time of
Kant's somebody you're going to be later
in the semester an ontological argument
for God's existence he's famous for a
lot of other things too but we're going
to focus on that and you find this
ontological argument in prosto genome
which is one of the many books that he
wrote Pro solo June is the one that we
are going to read this semester and I'm
going to talk in a couple minutes about
you know what promotive means and you
know how to read it and that sort of
thing but first I wanna think about this
for a minute
so you've got a monk right the monks
generally believe in God yeah and he is
coming up with an argument for God's
existence why would he do that what did
it look good with that do you think when
do you come up with arguments for things
a little bit when you don't believe it
something yeah sometimes you like if you
didn't believe in God you might want to
come up with an argument against God's
existence all right who would you make
an argument about God's existence - yeah
now were there a lot of people who
didn't believe in God in the Middle Ages
song but not too many right that was the
age of faith wasn't it as what as we
told everybody in the history classes
you know who he actually wrote this - he
wrote this to his fellow monks what do
you think he's going on there hyssop his
monks you know the other monks
presumably they believe in God right
otherwise why are they sitting around
the monastery not you know going out and
getting married and wearing these you
know uncomfortable garments and and
doing all this work and listening to you
know somebody tell them what to do well
that's something to think about why why
does he try to come up with an ID but
we've got an idea like a proof for the
existence of God why did the theologians
do this sort of thing you know you could
if you want to be joking about this you
could say so dr. Sandler can people
lecture about it you know
800 years later or something like that
actually 900 years later Anselm's
celebration of an Psalms 900 year
anniversary of his death was just a
couple of years ago but that's not the
reason so why do people do this well
they want to know first of all whether
you can do it there's there's
intellectual curiosity there remember we
talked about metaphysics with Aristotle
a little while back and we talked about
all these different Arts and Sciences
why people do them you know for instance
why did people figure out how to make
coffee well because we like the taste of
coffee right so that barista behind the
counter at Starbucks who's taken some
you know course on coffee whatever I
forget what they call it they have to
take some sort of coffee making course
they really do have Starbucks coffee
culture or something they're learning a
useful art right the person who works on
my cell phone on my cell phone breaks
down there's a reason for that it's a
useful art they're gonna make it work
for me and why do I need itself well
call people to check my email surf the
web that's right stuff just it you know
carry it around
what about metaphysics why do we do
metaphysics do we do it because it
provides us any sort of tangible good
like that
what good have you gotten out of
studying metaphysics so far does it made
you wealthy healthier
have you had anything I've studied
metaphysics this semester you can be
honest makes you think okay and is that
a pleasurable thing or is that an
unpleasant thing I got you me honestly I
don't I've been teaching required
philosophy classes my entire career so
nothing that students can say to me
about how this class is terrible I wish
I'd never had to do this I'm never gonna
study this again doesn't hurt my
feelings at all that that could be the
case is that is that the case with
anybody no I'm very surprised if it's
not on the other hand there's some
people who took this class and they've
never read Plato before and after this
class is finished probably not you know
right after the the semester but later
out in their career they're gonna study
Plato again you know why why where are
they gonna go back to Plato or Aristotle
or epictetus or in some cuz they found
something there that made them think
that got its hooks into them that maybe
it even you know gave them a headache
but somehow it aroused their curiosity
maybe gave them a certain sort of
pleasure people like to think about
things right we don't all like to think
about exactly the same thing but we do
like to think about things like
Aristotle said all people desire to know
you want to know the causes for things
so for some of you seen Anselm Anna's
ontological argument is going to be
something that you would actually enjoy
thinking about more and more after this
class is finished after you no longer
have to read them some of you will go
back and reread it and you'll say wow I
didn't realize that this
was there that was me about 15 years ago
that was actually Anselm himself if you
read what he says about in the
introduction to the pro slow Jim he says
that he wrote another book before this
right called the moral laws you and that
book was a whole bunch of arguments and
if you read it it is it's got like 60
chapters I forget exactly how many and
it's all about God and you know the
nature of God and you know all the sun
proceeds from the father you know the
Sun is generated from the father and the
spirit proceeds from both and what that
means and etc etc etc and all this this
theological stuff it's very complicated
and all that and some wanted to try to
find one single simple argument that
could do all of that stuff and not
require any others any other arguments
or or assumptions in order to to prove
itself and so we started thinking about
this I'm going to be read the
introduction and anybody read it yet
when you get done here read the
introduction because what he says is I
thought about it and then I I didn't
think I could do it and like you know
everybody else when the Anselm didn't
think he could do it what did he do what
are you doing we don't think you can do
something
yeah he gave up he said this is a waste
of time I could be spending my time on
other stuff this is actually a
distraction then you know Nampa what
happens when you try not to think about
something like right now nobody think
about Barack Obama singing the national
anthem don't think about everybody's not
thinking about that what's actually
going through your mind you've got some
image of Barack Obama maybe standing
somewhere maybe the singing maybe isn't
right if you try not to think about
something and often impresses itself on
this argument did that to an some it did
it so much that he actually thought that
it was the devil trying to make him
waste his time and be a bad monk and
he's sort of like forbade himself to
think about it and then one day the he
had a breakthrough and suddenly he saw
what it is that we're going to be
looking at in just a couple minutes
and again if you read through that
introduction
he doesn't say I saw that this would be
a really great way to convince people
who don't believe that God exists that
God does exist what he said is it filled
me with such joy this argument that I
thought I would write it down so I could
communicate that to others now you know
I don't know if any of you experience
joy reading this I certainly didn't the
first you know two or three even you
know like 20 times if you stick with it
though and this goes for any
philosophical work this also goes for
any great novel any great historical
piece if you stick with it and you will
in fact come to come to enjoy it you
will get joy from it you will get
pleasure from and that's what's that's
what the Anselm is trying to bring
across so let's look at what anybody
actually said so we're only going to
look at
we look at three chapters today chapters
two through four of the Provo Jew and
the reason that we're doing the app is
because those are the chapters where
this what gets called the ontological
argument for God's existence VeriFone is
that everything that's going on in the
Prost well Jim no we're going to talk
about more of the stuff that's going on
in a pro so Jian next class session but
this class session we're going to try to
wrap our heads around a very tricky
proof which you may find completely
convincing even though you don't want to
which has been my experience sometimes
or you may find completely baffling at
first and then as you start to
understand you may say this is this
still doesn't make any sense or you may
say oh now I get it you may think
there's some sort of sleight of hand you
know like a magician pulling the rabbit
out of the Hat going on with this
because it almost seems like just out of
the idea of God ants on the manages to
pull got pretty good magic trick so
let's see how he actually does
he starts out we're gonna ignore all the
prayers stopping but he is actually you
know talking to God well he's well he's
claiming to prove God's existence that's
kind of strange too isn't it you know
you can tell he believes that God exists
so he says I'm going to kind of change
the language so does kind of exist we
believe that God is something man which
nothing greater can be thought so this
is one of the key terms and actually
before we go on let's think about this
little thing
what does that mean let's think of some
examples so think of Barack Obama
singing the national anthem again is
Barack Obama a great singer anyone ever
heard him say it could be yeah maybe he
opens his mouth and he sounds like
Pavarotti or something
probably not gonna be the case though
can you think of anything greater than
Barack Obama when it comes to singing
I'm willing to bet you can think of all
sorts of things that are greater all
sorts of singers for are better singers
right can you think of anything bigger
than Barack Obama
physically are there any people bigger
than him pulling any size yeah there are
a lot of people you guys sure and now
let's say we keep you know stacking em
up and we go to the next person you know
let me say this person is really big
let's see me actually find the tallest
person in the world right now could you
think of somebody being thicker than
them yeah just watch them science
fiction stuff I think of like another
you know some hormone that makes people
get bigger so if the biggest guy in the
world is currently 8 feet tall which I
don't know maybe that's the case maybe
not can you imagine somebody bigger than
that sure you can imagine somebody 9
feet tall right if somebody is very wise
like who do you consider particularly
wise particularly intelligent anybody
you know I mean don't say like something
like my mother because we don't know
your dad anybody public it's really
super smart
although he's an example the girl aaaa
they actually went to high school Herod
said it's a middle school with who
became a person who you know does stuff
with NASA well she was pretty smart
there's probably some harder than me
she's working for NASA they put her in
charge of things can I think of anybody
smarter sure
Stephen marking right the guy in the
wheelchair who does all the physics
stuff and comes out with books every so
often could there be anybody smarter
than him sure we can think of somebody
smarter than him does Stephen Hawking
know about mathematics sure does he know
about all the possible different ice
cream cleaners probably none so somebody
who knew about not just all the
mathematics that you could think of but
also ice cream flavors it would be
smarter wouldn't they
you see how this works right so for most
things that you can think of you can
think of something greater than that
that can't you what about numbers can
you think of the greatest number think
of the biggest number you can think of
now add one to it you you've just now
thought of a a greater number right so
pick any attribute or any quality that
you like it seems like for most things
you can think of something that's
greater can't you think of the best time
you've ever had in your life the best
experience you've had so far can you
think of it can you think of anything
that you could add to that experience
that would make it even better like you
went to this concert and your
you know there with all your friends and
the weather was just perfect and it was
the band that you always wanted to see
and you never did get to see and you
what else coming add to this you you
want to contest so you got to eat and
drink and everything that you wanted
from the concession stand and somebody
in the band saw you and got gave me
backstage passes not just for you but
for all your friends and do you have
anything more do that it sounds pretty
good
I'm sure all of you to think of other
things you could add to that right what
else might add to something you want
another contest you walked out of there
with a thousand bucks in your pocket
that would make it even better wouldn't
it they audit the band autographed your
shirt which now you're never gonna wash
we can keep coming up with all of these
sorts of things
now think about like a really good
person what qualities will they have
what are you looking for
what do you look for in a potential mate
or even a friend being nice yeah do you
don't want people who are being here
right
that's pretty baseline know what let's
let's let's really raise the bar as high
as we can
yes trustworthy that's what's great what
else
how about good-looking anybody want you
know a mate that's good-looking or are
you all like you know so far beyond
appearance this that that doesn't matter
to you at all let's just throw that in
what else yeah
or you were raising him because you can
think of all sorts of different
qualities but no matter what qualities
you think of you could probably think of
it being a bit better adding another
quality this is one reason why people
often get to satisfy to ISM because you
can imagine all sorts of things could
there be something then you couldn't
think anything better or anything
greater then that's what we're working
with here you know when when people talk
about God we have all different sorts of
ideas of God right what are some of the
ideas that people have of God that are
not very attractive
then you've encountered in your life
how about God is the guy in the sky
who's got a long white beard and he's
got a whole set of rules and if he
violate his rules he's gonna get you
what do you think was a very attractive
picture of God could you think of
anything better than that
and what could you think of that's
better than that what it kind of gives
you second chances and you know when you
do the wrong thing and then he says I
don't want you to do that the next time
I'm gonna get you but this time I'm
gonna let you off so that you can try to
fix things wouldn't that be better I
want to do it prefer that that God to
strike a dead guy yeah and then we could
we think about war and more things so
those are probably not very good
pictures of God right what do people
mean when they say God what are
religious believers I mean when they're
talking about God well Ansel says this
is one of the things that they'll often
mean something Dan which nothing greater
can be thought if you even think of
something greater that other greater
thing would be God so you know let's say
God exists and God made everything but
there's something that controls God but
we wouldn't call God God then we'd call
that thing that controls God God because
that would be greater than God if
there's something that we're going to
worship and say is you know the highest
we really want it to be the highest
don't worry so God is something the
anguish nothing greater can be thought
now if you just say something like that
does that mean everybody automatically
believe
No Anselm says there's there's this you
know passage of the Bible where the
Bible talks about people not believing
in God the Bible has this figure of the
fool and if you look into the wisdom
literature where wisdom is the opposite
of foolishness one of the things that
makes a fool a fool is thinking there's
no God and then behaving like there is
no God so you know screwing people over
cheating lying stealing and saying hey
it doesn't matter there's no God to do
anything to me I can do anything I like
so I'm gonna you know abuse the the weak
yeah take advantage of people that's
what that's what the biblical fool does
in an Stumpf's case the fool just says
there is no God so if you say to the
pool if you say to somebody who's an
unbeliever we're gonna get rid of the
term the fool though because it's kind
of derogatory right say somebody who
doesn't believe in God somebody who
doesn't believe in God can at least
understand this this phrase right that
damn there's nothing greater can be
thought and they can understand that God
and these to the religious believer is
nothing
but what is the what does the
non-believer say they say there's no
such thing that's just an idea and
where's the idea where do you keep your
ideas it's out of your pockets right let
me keep my car keys my pockets but no
idea is there pens
it's like that where do you keep your
ideas yeah
whereas my daughter you say in your
noggin you know and that's kind of a
metaphor right I mean are your I suppose
if you think that that your brain is is
your whole mind then that's it
right so your ideas are literally there
in your head what do we mean by that in
your in your mind and your as an some
sense in your understanding just an ID
yeah your money now notice at this point
the the non-believer has the idea of God
in their mind too don't they they they
think that it's just in their mind
though right doesn't exist in reality
just in the mind so everybody everybody
has followed along so far right so what
do we have so far God is is that than
which nothing greater can be thought
among other things when people are
talking about God they just have this
idea in their head there's nothing
actually out there in reality
corresponding to that idea it's just an
idea that you have in your head and as
soon as you start thinking about it
you've got it in your head or in your
mind and your understanding so you have
the idea of that then which nothing
greater can be thought in your mind so
does an Psalms fool so it has ants on
himself
so do i so what is whoever is watching
this this
video right maybe 30 years from now you
guys are all you know the mid stage of
your career so many people watching this
and as soon as they hear that phrase
that then which nothing greater can be
thought they have it in their mind now
could this be the case let's assume this
actually is the case in some sense let's
say that all this stuff that religious
believers say about God exists and you
know mighty God and bla bla bla bla bla
that's all beat us that's all just
imaginary stuff that they made up and
they tell themselves stories to make
themselves feel good whatever story you
like about about that sort of thing
that's what's going on so we're going to
assume something like that
we're going to assume it that we're
going to see if that really works and if
it doesn't work then one has to be the
case let's say we assume that God
doesn't exist in reality but there's a
contradiction what is that
well let's think about other similar
cases you get the fight with your best
friend and your best friend says that
they've been completely loyal to you and
you say well okay I'm going to assume
that you are completely loyal to me but
then this would follow and this would
follow but that's a contradiction that
can't actually be the case what
conclusion do you draw
and do this sort of thinking all the
time maybe your friends not completely
loyal to you because you assumed that
they were and some sort of contradiction
arose something that couldn't be the
case that must mean that they the
opposite is true right so if we can show
that if we assume this some sort of
contradiction arises this has to be
false what would that mean that would
mean God has to exist so let's see if
that can be done
the Anselm says there isn't any such
thing it's just an idea in your head
that exists in your understanding as he
says he introduces another thing says it
is greater in reality then just
understanding imagine your that doesn't
even have to be your perfect mate or
perfect meal or perfect whatever you
like what you're gonna do after you get
out here what are you gonna do we're all
gonna go back and dance all right
no that's the hope you get at least
they're honest enough shake your heads
what are you gonna do right that I hope
most of you are going to dinner right
now
does anybody know what's on the menu for
dinner tonight at the cafeteria yeah
what's it let's say it's lasagna
right since we don't know
imagine the lasagna that was Anya now
exists in your mind doesn't imagine all
the wonderful qualities that lasagnas
what do you like about those does
everybody hear my clothes aren't you
anybody who doesn't like lasagna and
okay then this work what do you like
about lasagna what's that it's cheesy
there's that and that texture you know
what it's just the right temperature
what else about it I have all those up
what are you guys like just the cheese
nothing else why not just need a bump
you know a bunch of cheese then yeah
presumably the noodles place on old as
well okay so you've got that you're
imagining that your mind right now eat
them everybody full everybody is
satisfied did you enjoy the taste of it
it's gonna be better to have that real
as Anya isn't real lasagna is is greater
lasagna that exists in reality this is
greater than it was on you that just
exists in your head where you know let's
let's use an example that actually
there's $20 all right this is a $20 bill
it's a real thing where does this spend
most of its time in my wallet in my
pocket this could be euros it already is
inside your head Craig because you're
looking at it now you have this this
image in your mind don't you
I don't need to give you $20 then you've
got $20 already right doesn't that just
as good or is it greater to exist in
reality has real $20 than to just be an
imagined $20 a thought $20 even $1 right
okay so all of you get this right it's
greater to exist in reality than just to
exist in remind does anybody see any
problems with that everybody agrees with
it okay so let's think that about today
give god there's no such idea
in reality yeah that that much nothing
greater can be thought so can you think
of anything greater than this idea in
your mind of that that much nothing
greater can be fun
what if they have 10 which nothing
greater can be thought actually existed
in reality are you thinking of that
right now where is it
existing that where is that idea in your
mind right because you're thinking of it
so if that than which nothing greater
can be thought doesn't exist in reality
and you can think of something greater
than is it really that damage
can be thought let's go through that one
more time because it's kind of tricky so
god is that that much nothing greater
can be thought God doesn't exist in
reality just just as an idea but it's
better to exist in reality it's greater
to exist in reality than it is just to
exist in the mind is an idea you can
think of that right so you can imagine
something which is that damage nothing
greater can be thought existing in
reality that doesn't mean that it
actually exists in reality yet but you
can imagine it and if you can imagine
that you have now thought of something
greater than what nobody was supposed to
be able to think something greater then
that's a contradiction isn't you have
that that much nothing greater can be
thought being something that something
can be thought greater it's sort of like
saying two is not equal to two or ice
cream is not the same thing as the stuff
made out loud as ice cream in a milk and
help and you know flavors and things
like that there's a contradiction so
remember what we said about there being
a contradiction what was going to happen
if there was a contradiction you
remember back about ten minutes ago what
was gonna happen if there if we assumed
this and there was a contradiction what
are we gonna say somebody's got
say it's okay this has to be false so if
if it's false that there isn't any such
thing what's the opposite of that there
is such a thing that then which nothing
greater can be thought does exist not
just in your mind but in reality it's
kind of tricky isn't it this is one that
you got to read through a couple times
and sort of wrap your head around in
order to make sense of it yeah I still
myself through this day and I'm a person
who actually finds this convincing
I still go through moments where I say
this can't possibly be true there's got
to be something wrong going on here and
I had I used to be on the other side
where I was where I was saying this
can't possibly be true I can't believe
this and yet it was sort of you know
pulling at me and said maybe it could be
maybe there is some logic there and I
wavered back and forth so and so if
you're wavering back and forth that's
okay Ansem I think would probably
understand that perfectly well he talks
as if this is gonna convince you
automatically like that I'm guessing
that your experience as we've gone
through this has not been that you had
an aha moment where you said oh God
exists great all of my feelings were
solved
did anyone anyone didn't hear you have
that that moment if you stick with it
you may actually have a moment like that
it may not be a lasting moment Bertrand
Russell had a moment like that and that
later on sir to recant it but it is an
interesting argument look at the way
that it works you assume something to be
the case in order to prove that that
can't be the case so that something else
must be the case you assume that God
doesn't exist
in order to show that some sort of
contradiction arises so that therefore
God must exist tricky way of doing it
isn't it that's not like you know doing
a proof in geometry or you know about
angles or proving to somebody that that
Colonel Mustard did indeed kill the
person in the parlor with the
candlestick it's not really that kind of
proof is it so if that's perfectly clear
to you all then we'll go on to Chapter
three
if it's not clear then then tell me what
what doesn't make sense and don't be shy
about doing perfectly understandable to
me if some of this were to seem fishy to
you is there anything in here that seems
fishy to anybody
what do you think needs to be decide
that there it does exist or it doesn't
exist we decided that this sentence
there isn't any such thing the thing
that the non-believers son there isn't
any such thing as God it's just an idea
in your head it has to be false because
it led to contradictory conclusions so
what has to be true is the opposite of
it
which is that God does exist good it's
important to be clear about these things
anything else that seems a little fishy
in here you not everybody accepted this
proof as a matter of fact one of the ant
songs fellow mothers raised some
problems it's not in the reading
selection that we have but if you if you
go on the same website that the reading
selections were coming from jasper
hopkins website the reply by agony low
on behalf of the fool Gunilla doesn't
accept it
i'm going to add some replied back to
him saying what you should accept it
reasons why well think about this and
then actually next Monday when we take
this up again if any of you can find a
problem with this bring it up and then
we'll go over it or if there's something
in it that's not clear to you some some
part where you didn't see why we made
the transition that we didn't bring it
up because I want you to be able to I'm
not I'm not so interested in whether you
agree with it or not
I don't care whether you believe in God
or you don't believe in God
or find this convincing or don't find it
convincing I want to I want to find out
whether you understand it or not and
this is a difficult proof to understand
I think on a deep level well let's look
them and what we have left of class yes
chapter three
so now we know God exists and Anselm
goes a little bit farther they says
actually God can't be thought not to
exist that's the title of chapter 3
pretty pretty provocative he says this
being exists so truly it reads it cannot
even be thought not to exist so again if
you have ban ban which nothing greater
can be fought and that's God let's say
that you want to take the side of the
fool you said wait a second just five
minutes ago we were saying there was at
least one person who thought that God
didn't exist right maybe just one
chapter ago he says if you could think
that this doesn't exist then that then
which a greater cannot be thought would
not be that than which a greater could
not be thought how how is that yeah okay
so let's let's start out with this God
is
God can be fought not to exist
and this play we said right I mean
there's all sorts of things that that
exist that you may not know about right
for you to think aren't the case like
let's end this up what's in this Cup
anybody know exactly what's in this Cup
take a guess what's that coffee of some
sort yeah but what coffee exactly it's
not hazel and now you know you could
think that there's hazel and there isn't
okay
or maybe I'm lying to you maybe now you
don't think that that hazelnut coffee
exists in this common though it does you
can think of them right we can have a
debate about it you know if you want to
resolve it you open it up and smell it
no no hazelnut and now you fixed it with
God does everybody believe God exists
there's some people right I don't
believe God exists presumably they can
actually think that God doesn't exist
because they're saying yeah so how can
you so possibly be saying that God
cannot be thought not to exist well
hopefully this logic so we assume this
God can be sometimes exist so
and not exist everybody no problem with
that right all we did is change the
terms a little bit we're like you know
substituting in a variable in an
equation is it greater to be the kind of
being that can't be thought not to exist
is it greater than being the kind of
being that could not exist okay the kind
of tricky it's a wrap your head around
so I'm gonna say this one more time try
to try to think through this
two heads beings beings that that could
not exist like you and me I didn't have
to exist neither did you the reason why
you exist is your mom and dad some night
got together and you know did their
thing nature took its course and get
fertilized your mom carried you to term
and then a bunch of other things happen
and you won't appear Marist right same
thing with me did my mom and dad have to
get together maybe my mom could have
hooked up with somebody else maybe your
mom could have maybe your dad could have
we're what we call contingent beings we
don't have to exist what about the you
know this iPhone 5 years ago this thing
didn't exist did it have to exist was
there anything in the nature of things
that said an iPhone must come into
existence one of the iPhones the first
get invented five years back maybe ten
years back the prototypes I don't know
what about this wallet
does they have to exist not even the
leather that a consistent has to exist
that came from some cow did that cow
have to exist could add a whole bunch of
other cause of its place this leather
could have been used for something else
do they have to be put together in this
way No so these are all contingent
things could anything be such then it
has to exist can you think of something
the kind of thing where it would have to
exist and you're at least you have that
thought in your head okay so we agree
then things
and things now you all remember that
where we went last argument what's going
to happen after this if you're thinking
that God or that damage nothing greater
can be thought can be thought not to
exist then you can actually think of
something greater than that can't you
namely something that can't be thought
not to exist so that then which nothing
greater can be thought you just thought
of something greater than which again
generates what a what do we call it now
a dilemma a search to the sea
contradiction and if we have a
contradiction we have to reject the
thing that started the contradiction so
God can be thought not to exist we have
to change one letter there to can't
write so God can not even be fought not
to exist
who knew okay did you start out today
thinking that you would find out that
that not only must there be a god
that you can't even not think that that
God exists doesn't that seem a little
fishy again so you know the argument
seems pretty good though doesn't it have
you finally has anybody found any weak
points in the argument yet yeah
well you wouldn't have physical proof of
God right because my assumption God
isn't a physical thing you can have
physical proof of water freezing because
water is a physical thing
it's got interesting you know in the we
were in this Barbara's race with the
Soviets right the Soviets radius and
they got it they got into space ahead of
us and just to sort of stick it to us
because you know we're big in the United
States most people were Christians one
of the cosmonauts was like looking
around in space and he said I don't see
any angels up here therefore God doesn't
exist
well that doesn't actually solve
anything does it because it's not that
sort of thing the kind of the line that
you're taking is a line that's similar
to what Thomas Aquinas who are you look
at next week would would say you have to
have some other way of proving it just
just talking about it isn't going to to
do it because what this looks like is
that we start with an idea in our head
and we just sort of stick inside of our
head and think about stuff and boom
there's God out there somehow now
there's two ways to think of that and
this is where I'm actually going to -
and let's say just for the sake of
assumption that all this stuff is
actually valid and the ontological
argument does hold and all that what's
actually going on this is where we get
to the sort of the metaphysics part and
not just the philosophy religion part so
here's so here's you
there's a lot more all right and I'm not
going to try to relate that then which
nothing greater can exist in here I'm
just gonna call that guy all right
you've got got out of your thought and
if the ontological argument actually
works this may be part of what you feel
is kind of walk about it
the Kevin looks like we didn't have God
existing before hand because it was up
for dispute right and because you Lee
happened to manage to think about God in
a certain way boom there's God
necessarily existing in such a way that
nobody can ever think that he doesn't
exist anymore
pretty dancer that was the case
something would be happening then he
says shouldn't happen
this isn't chapter three so I'm going to
read you a little bit of this he says if
any mind could think of something better
than you the creature what does he say
it would rise above the creator and
would sit in judgment over the Creator
something which is utterly absurd if God
could be the sort of thing that we could
inject into reality by just our thinking
about it that would mean we would
actually be greater than God right if
God comes from office if we put it a
different way if God comes into being
because we think of God that would mean
we'd be like God's created women do you
think that's what Anselm has in mind
probably wouldn't make sense for for a
committed Christian monk to think of
what if instead it's something more like
this
God exists in reality and because God
exists in reality